les vacances de pâques les touristes
sont au rendez-vous en bretagne le beau
temps qui règne depuis un mois et demi
sur la région n'est pas étranger à ce
succès un succès d'en bénéficier en
particulier les îles bretonnes réputés
pour leur tranquillité olivier piou
gabriel kenya c'est un signe qui ne
trompe pas sur le bateau ce matin il y
avait du monde beaucoup de monde les
voyez vous c'est aussi la magie du mil
bretonne il suffit de s'enfoncer un peu
d'ombré à pour ne plus croiser que de
temps à autre
ces visages entraperçu sur la vedette et
ça on en redemande et petits jardins
clos et des choses comme ça donc je
trouve que c'est typique aux îles
bretonnes en fait brian pas de voiture
fatal est appréciable aussi il ya ceux
qui sont là le ton d'un dimanche
ensoleillé et puis il ya les fidèles de
toujours prenez caroline et sa soeur
elle viennent ici depuis qu'elles sont
toutes petites bréhat
non elle ne s'en lasse pas on est dans
un esprit complètement différent que si
on était effectivement à saâdi km mais
pas entourée d'eau sur le continent là
on est bloqué en fait on est vraiment et
une coupure spatiale et temporelle
mousse plus prosaïquement étonnez vous
après cela que les il a fait le plein à
pâques guerre en irak marée noire du
prestige pneumopathie où tant de raisons
de se replier vers la bretagne
et si déjà les parisiens font leurs
valises les commerçants se font leurs
comptes mais on travaille à bréhal
pourquoi avec les
ils vont secondaire les parisiens
surtout et c'est vrai que là ils sont
partis il ya déjà eu des départs hier et
ce matin mais
on travaille beaucoup avec les parisiens
et laâyoune et puis pas que c'est
souvent l'occasion pour les touristes de
repérer les lieux en vue des grandes
vacances alors rien que pour notre
copine la mouette promis on reviendra
prince est sûre c'est tellement bon